well Francesca albanizi is the UN
special repertoire on the occupied
Palestinian territories she joins us now
live from New York good good to have you
with us so tell us how this report does
it represent a step forward in
documenting in the un's documenting of
Life under occupation for the
Palestinians
I think he does
and he does not
it does in the sense that it builds on
the conclusions and findings of my
predecessor that apart that Israel
commits the crime of apartheid in the
occupied Palestinian territory but
brings it Forward saying that apartheid
is a natural consequence it's an organic
consequence of settler colonialism for
the same reason that the general
assembly until 30 years ago was
describing
the current reality in the occupied
Palestinian territory a violation of the
right of self-determination and
inscribing it in the context of colonial
practices this discourse has sort of
toned down in recent years because of
the Oslo process but this is where it
still belongs the Palestinian situation
is a cause that call for decolonization
I'm sure you're aware that the report
has been accused and you've been accused
of being anti-semitic how do you respond
to that
agree and they find it very convenient
dismissing anyone who raises criticism
against the current practices of the
Israeli government
as anti-semitic this is convenient
because it allows them not to engage
with the substance of fully well solidly
documented reports and again I intend I
mean I want to stress that this is
anti-Semitic the anti-semitic label is
being used for human rights mechanisms
and reputable ngos at International
and domestic level against Palestinians
and Israelis so this is why I'm saying
it's very convenient but I I hope that
others can see can see that
there are of course a number of
international organizations credible
organizations that have described what
how Israel
um is ruling Palestinians as in
occupation even as an apartheid
including an Israeli human rights
organization bit selum are you surprised
at how you've been singled out and this
report has been singled out to be
accused of anti-semitism
it has not been singled out and again as
I as I say everyone who raises a
critical voice with a V what Israel is
doing is labeled as anti-semitic and
it's but Salem has been probably the
most vocal
um but not the first Israeli
organization to point to the to the to
to the conduct of Israel and Israeli
occupation as an apartheid
um because there is another Israeli
organization yesh Dean who had made the
same argument just a few months before
so there is a wall-to-wall consensus
that what Israel is doing is apartheid
and again I say it's a natural
consequence of the fact that Israel
maintains a settler Colonial occupation
in the occupied territory because it's
it violates a territorial sovereignty of
the Palestinians it acquires natural
resources of the Palestinians it
represses any form of Palestinian
political activity and activism and it
tends to erase the Palestinian cultural
identity this is what settler
colonialism is about all right you
mentioned that consensus arriving
amongst all these International
organizations but the question then
remains what happens to this report to
reports like the one which you've
produced will they actually have any
impact on the daily reality of life
yeah I should have qualified the world
to all consensus among human rights
lawyers human the human rights Community
has unified in exposing the apartheid
practices that Israel put in place of
course this is still to be absorbed and
acted upon by member states and
um it's clear this is why I say it's the
right of self-determination that imposes
obligations on Israel but also upon all
member states because the right of
self-determination is erga homeless it's
a it entails obligations for everyone so
international law is as valid and as
strong as the will of states to enforce
it so I I still remain hopeful that they
will be able uh to walk the talk of
legality and morality otherwise the
entire un system the entire
International Community will be
tarnished the report makes the point
that this occupation is as you put a
form of settler colonialism explain to
us what sort of practices LED you to
that conclusion
first of all
um the right of self-determination is
the right of all people
to determine their political future to
express their political will and enjoy
their Economic Development it's the
right to exist as a people and Israel
prevents the four components of the
right of self-determination as I said by
fragmenting seizing annexing territory
that on which International consensus is
that this belongs to the state of of
Palestine which by the way it's 22
percent of what was a historical
Palestine so this is the first violation
of the territorial dimension of the
right of self-determination but also
there is a part of this acquisition
translates into economic exploitation
for the benefit of businesses and and
and the settler the colonies at the
expense of the of the use of water land
quarries and oil for the Palestinians so
at the detriment of a potential
Palestinian economy but also you see
when shirena was killed the running
after the pallbearers carrying the
coffin and the flag is emblematic of
where does Israel stand vis-a-vis any
symbol of Palestinian identity which is
the third element erasion of culture and
of course also there is the prevention
of political will and political activity
that is epitomized by the fact that
Israel now not only prevents the
formation of an authentic and free
political will but also repressing
reputable human rights organization
trying to protect Palestinian Freedom so
there is no Freedom under occupation
all right thank you so much Francesca
adenesi Dev